serge dassault on a beaucoup dit et on
le dit beaucoup après chaque salon de
l'aéronautique que ce sera peut-être le
dernier qu'il y a de grosses difficultés
et puis finalement on se retrouve
et quand aujourd'hui on circule dans le
salon on s'aperçoit qu'ils aient un
monde qui a une foule énorme qui vient
vous voir
alors à quoi est-ce qu'on peut attribuer
ce succès du salon de l'aviation
je crois que ce succès est dû à la tire
et que présent pour l'opinion publique
et les industriels les techniciens
l'industrie aéronautique
nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
cette année je crois environ 30% de plus
de visiteurs qu'il ya deux ans ça monde
que pour l'opinion publique l'industrie
les avions sont intéressants et qu'il va
les voir de près nous avons interrogé
les gens qui sont venus et qui viennent
et nous on y venait voir les avions et
surtout à lyon volley et je crois que
c'est très important non seulement pour
les gens qui s'intéressent à l'aviation
mais surtout pour les enfants et nous
sommes très heureux de voir beaucoup
d'enfants des jeunes même de dix ans qui
viennent joueurs qui connaissent
d'ailleurs beaucoup de choses et qui
expliquent à leurs parents de leur
journée vu un ou à la le mirage voilà
l'étendard concorde revoilà le un
hélicoptère et ce qui prouve que pour la
jeunesse l'aviation représente quelque
chose
je
pour la mère du christ important parce
que si beaucoup de jeunes veulent
devenir ingénieur devenir pilote faire
des études techniques et construire des
matériels électroniques de radars ou
autre c'est fondamental pour l'avenir du
pis faut bien leur montre il faut leur
donner la vocation je crois que le sens
du bourget une démotivation ce salon est
justement d'essayer de susciter des
vocations
alors ceci c'est l'aspect grand public
mais il ya aussi l'aspect des
professionnels est ce que les
restrictions de sécurité enfin il paraît
que ce salon est saoul vigilance du
général des pompiers de paris qui
surveille la sécurité est-ce que cet
aspect de sécurité n'a pas quand même
eux diminué l'intérêt des présentations
et bien je crois que je dirais peut-être
même au contraire parce que nous avons
effectivement défini des règlements de
sécurité plus strictes qu'il y a deux
ans mais ces règlements de suture des
finalement permettent de faire des
présentations en vol peut être plus
professionnel plus pur peut-être moins
risqués ce qui est le but d'ailleurs est
extrêmement belle et intéressante à voir
nous avons par exemple supprimés les
patrouilles
nous avons supprimé les présentations de
vol à plusieurs les avions à plusieurs
dons qui vole en solo mais pour
l'opinion publique voire un avion
évoluer un mirage faire sa présentation
avec ses virages serrés et quelque chose
de très intéressant et je crois que on
n'a jamais autant volé finalement que
cette année est ce que vous ne craignez
pas justement d'évoluer vers un salon
réservé aux professionnels qui vous
couperez finalement de l'intérêt du
public que vous souhaitez
cela pourrait avoir lieu si le salon ne
se tenait plus au bourget et c'est pour
ça que nous voulons absolument qu'il se
tienne au bon dieu pour tous pour
remplir ces deux fonctions fondamentales
informer l'opinion publique contre et
l'aviation jeunes et aussi travailler
car pour l'industrie nautique le salon
du bourget
est un outil de travail extraordinaire
il permet de faire venir
des pays les plus lointains des
techniciens des exposants et de pouvoir
avoir des réunions des contacts et
peut-être même des contrats que l'on
n'aurait pas eu ce sens là et même au
hasard nous voyons cela toujours au
hasard des rencontres dans les chalets
ou des rencontres au salon même on
retrouve des amis
venant des états unis d'australie
d'allemagne d'afrique du sud que l'on
retrouve avec plaisir qu'ils sont tous
là on se retrouve on parle et
quelquefois on essaye d'établir des
projets de coopération
peut-être même des contrats ya un slogan
justement selon lequel le salon de paris
c'est la grande vitrine de l'industrie
aéronautique mondiale est ce que vous
pouvez justifier ce slogan je crois que
le salon tel qu'il est aujourd'hui le
justifient amplement c'est le salon du
bourget le seul salon où on voit
vraiment aux tacots des avions russes et
avions américains
les avions français anglais allemands
ont la même de l'avion polonais d avion
australien et c'est le seul endroit au
monde où on peut voir côte à côte et je
dirais même que non seulement cet aspect
d'intéressant son plan d avion mozy
sortant des équipements fournis oublie
un peu mais qui sont très importants
pour l'industrie et on voit des
équipements français anglais allemand
qui côte à côte dans les stands et il
faut visiter les stands le salon n'est
pas simplement le salon des avions c'est
le salon aussi des équipements
d'électronique à une des missiles il ya
des radars et tout ça forme un tout pour
l'aviation
il semble qu'il y ait un effort
particulier extrêmement important de
toutes les sociétés présentes au salon
et tout ce drainage de
grand patron qui viennent du monde
entier de leurs ingénieurs des
techniciens des pilotes font qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup de retombées en plus
pour la région parisienne pendant la
durée
oui c'est encore une une un désintérêt
du salon c'est que finalement la région
parisienne profitent beaucoup de la
venue à paris de tous ces étrangers
on me dit par exemple que les hôtels
sont pleins les restaurants sont pleins
même on parle de fleury s'ils sont
déportés
j'en parlais peut-être des boîtes de
nuit sans peine aussi et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que j'ai eue de
plusieurs personnes
la même opinion c'est la qualité des
gens qui viennent ici et par exemple que
vous dire que les grands patrons
américains les grands patrons de boeing
de westinghouse de yooz mcdonnell sont
présents à paris eux-mêmes pendant huit
jours ils sont là ils visitent ou même
le salon et prennent des contacts dire
ils sont intéressés par les contacts
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes avec non seulement
les français mais les hôtes étrangers
car ce salon à son international ou non
seulement nous essayons nous de vendre
les produits de l'industrie française
aussi les américains essayent de vendre
et arrive à vendre leurs produits aux
autres pays
effectivement ils sont là pour vendre et
la compétition est très très dur mais
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dénie des
deux des ventes justement de l'industrie
française est repartie les exportations
qu'est ce que ça représente pour
l'économie française
je veux vous dire que toutes les
entreprises françaises travaillant pour
l'aéronautique travail à peu près pour
60% pour l'exportation
il ya 60 % de leur chiffre d'affaires et
finalement payé par de l'argent étranger
donc on ne peut pas dire que c'est le
budget français qui alimente uniquement
aussi bien
honda sont inscrits à ce que matra au
thompson l'aliment pour 40 % de leur
activité
cela montre l'importance de
l'exportation pour l'industrie française
s'il n'y avait pas d'exploitation
l'industrie nautique française ne
pourrait pas vivre uniquement sur le
budget sur le marché français serge
dassault j'aimerais puisque c'est le
thème de l'émission qu'on parle un peu
de l'homme
serge dassault vous avez un nom bien sûr
que tout le monde connaît parce que
marcel dassault s'est depuis maintenant
plusieurs dizaines d'années c'est un
grand renom de l'aviation mondiale
alors comment quand on est le fils de
marcel dassault est ce que c'est évident
qu'on fasse de l'aviation et qu'on s'y
intéresse c'est pas évident il faut
aussi intéressé il faut faire des études
pour cela j'ai fait pour une technique
et super héros j'avais envie de faire
les violations d'essayer de suivre
disons les traces de mon père et
j'essaye de faire le mieux possible
dans cette voie c'est pas facile il ya
beaucoup de choses à apprendre beaucoup
de choses à savoir
mais je crois qu'il faut au moins
essayer de faire un homme c'est aussi
une équipe alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un peu de votre équipe
l'équipe de hand et l'équipe du salon
j'ai une très bonne équipe à
l'électronique marcel dassault j'ai une
très bonne équipe d excellents
ingénieurs techniciens qui permettent de
réaliser des très bon matériel qui en
général fonctionne bien le premier coup
ce qui est pas toujours facile quand on
voit aussi les difficultés de mise au
point n'a pas électronique aux états
unis en angleterre j'ai un élections
directeur général qui s'appelle johnny
et en ce qui concerne le salon j'ai
aussi heureusement très bonne équipe
directeur du salon monsieur lafon est un
homme qui connaît à fond ça son travail
qui vraiment mal dire m'amener le
minimum de travail de soucis pour
organiser ce salon
le fait d'organiser un salon comme celui
là qu'est-ce que ça crée comme souci
parce que ça doit pas se préparer en
quelques mois niant quelques semaines
c'est un énorme travail qui est
complémentaire de votre activité ou pas
sont pas complémentaires ça vient en
plus vous à dire que c'est la première
fois que j'organise un salon avec l'aide
de l'équipe
de l'union syndicale ça m'a donné
beaucoup de travail mais je dois dire
que le maximum de soucis que cette
organisation
mam n'est pas forcément pour ce salon là
mais pour le prochain car il faut
toujours travailler à l'avance un salon
se prépare deux ans à l'as vence et
aujourd'hui nous pensons déjà au futur
salon nous arrive au terme du 31e salon
vous avez vu beaucoup de fichiers le
président la république le premier
ministre
aujourd'hui comment voyez vous l'avenir
de l'industrie après tous les contacts
que vous avez pris au cours de ce long
la vie l'industrie
mais pour le moment pas mauvais grâce
aux commandes exportations que nous
avons pris que nous espérons prendre il
faut bien savoir que un avion se prépare
sept ou huit ans la vence et que si nous
voulons préparer la génération 1980 il
faut commencer maintenant
et là nous sommes un peu inquiet parce
que les crédits actuels et crédit la
défense nationale les crédits
budgétaires ne sont pas à notre avis
suffisant actuellement pour permettre un
développement
des matériels et en os tics moteurs
cellule équipement qui permettrait de
préparer cet avenir correctement alors
aujourd'hui le plan de charge
l'industrie nautique est bon grâce
exploitation mais nous pensons à venir
et je dois dire que nous sommes
inquiètes parce que ce budget le budget
76 en particulier en ce qui concerne la
défense et les matériels nouveaux que
nous devons préparer n'est pas
actuellement suffisant et si nous
pouvons pas faire demain les matériels
pour après demain on risque dans quatre
cinq six ans d'avoir de graves problèmes
par les problèmes si un chat souffre
mais en dehors du technicien vous êtes
du responsable d'entreprise vous avez
aussi et vous vous battez aussi pour une
certaine conception de l'entreprise ans
j'aimerais pour conclure que vous
puissiez nous en dire quelques mots
oui car je pense qu'une entreprise et 1
to est une équipe que healy a
effectivement des salariés dictionnaire
des patrons des chefs d'entreprise mais
que tout le monde travaille en fait pour
le même but c'est à dire fournir du
travail et produire des matières qui
puisse se vendre et je considère que
l'entreprise est une équipe où tout le
monde travaille ensemble pour le même
but
nous essayons d'associer l'ensemble du
personnel entreprise je pense que la
notion de lutte des classes est dépassé
quand on parle de salaire contre profit
le patron peut payer tout ça ce sont des
notions actuellement périmés et nous
nous battons pour le faire comprendre
parce que dans les entreprises qui
gagnent plus d'argent qui font le plus
et profite ce sont les entreprises ou
personnelles et le mieux payé ou
l'intéressement aux bénéfices permet de
encore payer plus ce personnel par un
treizième mois quelquefois un 14e mois
donc la conception de l'entreprise que
telle que nous la réalisons chez nous
consiste à associer les salariés n'ont
pas forcément aux décisions car cela
aussi une notion que dont on parle
actuellement mais à leur travail à la
responsabilité dans leur travail à
l'information nous ont beaucoup
d'informations il faut que les salariés
sachent ce qui se passe dans
l'entreprise je crois que il n'y a
jusqu'à présent un manque de liaison de
contact peut être un écran syndical qui
a fait que le personnel n'était pas
suffisamment motivé dans certaines
entreprises au seyant de casser cette
barrière est de faire comprendre à
l'ensemble du personnel que cette grande
équipe travaille pour un but commun
qu'il n'y a pas de lutte interne ce mot
de lutte n'est pas vrai est ce que le
symbole de voir toute une équipe
rassemblée autour d'un avion quand il
sort d'une usine est pour vous un bon
symbole
c'est un symbole extraordinaire car
quand on voit les mécaniciens quand on
voit les ouvriers qui ont travaillé est
quelquefois même des nuits des scènes du
dimanche pour finir un prototype pour le
mettre au point pour qu'il marche bien
on vraiment tout le monde travaille la
main dans la main pour le même but il
n'y a pas eu des classes dans cet état
d'esprit il n'y a qu'une seule équipe
qui travaille ensemble et c'est ça que
nous voulons faire comprendre non pas
une entreprise parce que l'entreprise où
cela est mais à l'opinion publique et
ils ont une certaine classe
intellectuelle
je vous remercie serge dassault
[Musique]